apple just announced the brand new ipad
air 4 and there's many reasons to buy
one
but there's also a few things that apple
conveniently
left out which you definitely have to be
aware of
before ordering these things will
literally stop
many of you from buying one and make the
ipad air 4
not worth it depending on what you do i
know at least a few of these will
surprise
all of you as they surprise us when we
figure them out
personally i think that many people will
be better off buying
a used or refurbished 2018 ipad pro
for the same amount or possibly even
less money
which i'll leave some links to down in
the description
or possibly spending the extra money and
getting a lot more features with a 2020
ipad pro
in this video i'll tell you not only
what you'll be missing out on
but also what you'll gain with the new
ipad air if you decide to buy it
so that you can make an informed
decision that you won't regret in the
future
on the outside the ipad air 4 looks
almost identical to the 2018
ipad pro it's very slightly thicker but
also lighter
the only visible difference to the
trained eye is that the power button is
larger
and that's because it's using apple's
new touch id that is embedded
into the power button the screen is
slightly smaller at 10.9 inches instead
of 11
and the resolution is dropped by just a
few pixels to match
you won't notice this in the real world
and i feel like the only reason apple
did that
is to separate it from their 11 inch
ipad pro
it's also fully laminated with p3 color
with true tone and the same grey
anti-reflectivity coating
so almost everything is the same but
there are two specific things
that changed which are a deal breaker
for me
but let's stick to the positives before
we get into the negatives
thankfully apple didn't ditch the quad
stereo speakers
which are a massive upgrade for playing
games and
watching movies along with that it also
takes usb
type c it has support for the new magic
keyboard which is overpriced but i still
absolutely love
and it now supports the apple pencil 2
which also means
if you have the first gen pencil you'll
need to buy the new one
the camera on the back looks identical
to the 2018 ipad pro
but for some reason apple didn't include
the quad led flash
which is actually very handy for
scanning documents
the front camera is still 7 megapixels
but it's also missing true depth sensors
so you won't have access to the memoji
animoji
or the portrait lighting features the
other interesting emission
is the five microphones that sounded
great for facetime calls
now there's only two microphones of
course we'll have to see how much of a
difference we have between the speakers
the cameras and the mics
in our hands-on comparison against the
ipad pro so make sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on that
there's also a few things that it does
better than the ipad pro
but since i started on the downsides
already let's get into
the biggest disappointments first let's
start with the most
obvious one no face id touch id is
fine but face id on the ipad pro is so
convenient from auto unlocking it by
just pressing on the keyboard to logging
into apps and using safari autofill
without ever having to stop what i am
doing is fantastic
and touch id is definitely a step back
the second
is the lack of pro motion which is a
shame
having that 120hz fluid display is one
of the key features that really stands
out on the ipad pros
not only does it make the ipad feel
super smooth and responsive
but it also allows the refresh rate to
drop down to match your content
so if you're watching a movie it runs at
24 frames per second
which looks like the director intended
and it actually saves
battery life at the same time promotion
is also what makes the ipad pro
by far the best tablet to write or draw
on with latency
so low that it's not even noticeable
since the ipad pro reads the pencil's
location
240 times per second the ipad airs
60 hertz screen will have more than
double the latency so basically the same
performance as the ipad pro
from 2016. the other common spec with
the 2016 ipad pro is the display
brightness the 2017 ipad pros and newer
all support 600 nits of brightness
which is 20 brighter than the new air
not only is that really handy in bright
rooms or outdoors but it also enables
hdr video which makes for a really
nice viewing experience with this new
air you'll not only miss
out on the darker more detailed shadows
and having brighter more realistic
highlights
but it will also use more power with the
display refreshing
more than twice as often as it needs to
now comes the really
weird part which i didn't expect and
that is the performance of the a14
bionic processor
we were surprised to see the apple put
the same processor that will come
in the iphone 12 into this mid-spec
tablet which will be
the first ever five nanometer processor
on the market with 11.8 billion
transistors
which is about 40 more than before apple
mentioned that it's 40
faster than the previous cpu and the
graphics ship is 30
faster which is a really good
improvement when we heard the specs we
figured that the new ipad air will have
a few downsides
but having that new processor will make
it a smart buy to future proof it
and it will perform better than the
older pros but actually
that is not the case those performance
improvements were based on the previous
ipad air
so we started to do the math ourselves
and in geekbench 5 cpu tests we should
get a multi-core score of about 4 000
which is respectable obviously beating
out the a12 in the previous air
but looking closer it is still about 15
slower than the ipad pro from two years
ago
onto graphics we should see a metal
score of about 6000
which once again is a good improvement
compared to b4
but it's not only slower than the 2018
ipad pro as you're probably
expecting by now which by the way is
over 50
faster but even the 2017
10 and a half inch ipad pro looks to be
potentially slightly
faster and then of course the 2020 is at
the very top
with that a12z now of course we don't
know which test apple was going off of
in the real world tests could be
different which will do a wide variety
of tests
once we get it in so make sure to ring
that notification bell
so how in the world can a two or even a
three year old
ipad which can be bought for cheaper
than the new air
be performing so well despite their much
older processors well those use x-series
processors which are designed for
tablets
with more graphics and cpu cores for
example the new a14 bionic has a six
core processor which has four high
efficiency cores
and two high performance cores while the
a12x in that 2018 ipad pro
has an a core processor that doubles the
high performance cores the same thing
goes for graphics with the a14 featuring
four core graphics
instead of seven or eight in the newer
ipad pros
so that's how the old ones are actually
still faster
now with that five nanometer design and
less cpu and gpu cores
we should also be seeing better battery
performance but for some reason apple is
still
advertising the same 10 hours of battery
life
i know that lack of the pro motion does
have some effect
but i guess we'll have to do a real
world battery life test when we get it
in
now the new ipad air does have a few
improvements over that 2018 ipad pro
like the new color options which you
won't get and it also has wi-fi six
but overall i would much rather buy a
used or refurbished 2018 ipad pro for a
similar price
and enjoy having hdr a brighter display
having a flash for documents having
a much smoother experience with the pro
motion display
and using the apple pencil and with that
the very convenient and quick face id
and on top of all of that we have the
much faster cpu
for productivity and gaming now for
those of you who don't want to buy a
used or refurbished ipad
there's also the 2020 ipad pro which
also
has wi-fi six not those colors but it
comes with more improvements
and at about 150 to 200 dollars more
for that extra cash you get all of the
benefits of the 2018 model
but in a brand new device that also gets
more and better cameras
gets lidar has faster cpu and gpu with
potentially double the ram
and double the base storage which is i
think the sweet spot for most people
if 64 gigabytes isn't enough for you on
the air you have to spend 150 dollars
more
to get 256 gigabytes so that's only
about 50
away from a new 128 gigabyte pro
so now that you know the full story it's
going to be up to you to see if the ipad
air
4 is worth it or if all the extras that
come with even the older ipad pros
make those a much better choice let me
know what you think and why
in the comment section i'll go ahead and
leave links to all the models including
the refurb ones down in the video
description
along with links to this sweet ultra
soft premium maxtec
shirt thank you guys for your support
make sure to click that subscribe button
above
as we're going to be doing a ton of
hands-on comparisons as soon as we get
it in
this has been max and i will see you in
the next video